now let's speak to our correspondent
shaman freeman powell who's been
spending the evening with fans in
trafalgar square in central london
sherman it looks like things have have
calmed down slightly but i suspect when
each one of those goals went and there
was a cracking atmosphere
definitely we cannot let the scenes
behind me confuse us because this crowd
down here have been absolutely
electrifying it did actually start off
quite chilled though it was a very
family-friendly event down here today
but with each goal the crowd revved up
especially after alicia russo back
healed it back into the goal the crowd
here went crazy and that's when the it's
coming home chance started but to be
honest i did have a look around and
that's when the swede fight fits the
fans actually started to go home because
at that point it became clear that the
lionesses had it it's been an
electrifying day it really has there
were people waving their flags around
singing football is coming home before
the game had even ended so it's been a
great day down here so much so we've
just heard from the mayor of london that
uh on sunday for the final the capacity
here will be raised to 7 000 so that
fans can enjoy that final game
[Applause]
shiman thank you